[Music]
well now we are taking you all the way
across the globe to Shanghai China
because that is where Captain Jack
Sparrow conquered the red carpet now
everybody wanted to be there but hardly
still got the invite because he was the
only u.s. TV show at the epic launch of
Johnny's new pirate adventure Captain
Jack Sparrow is back and we flew halfway
around the world to join Johnny Depp and
the cats of pirates of the caribbean
dead men tell no tales here at Shanghai
dancing
get ready it's gonna get weird things
are gonna get weird
Disneyland Shanghai we love it who
doesn't love a bit Disney game playing
Orlando's son in this fifth installment
is handsome 27 year old to Britain
Thwaites we're in Shanghai for the world
premiere of pirates how awesome is there
it's great I mean the reception from the
crowd is amazing they seem more excited
than I was when I found out I got the
role another pirates newcomer playing
the baddie and this one is Javier Bardem
his wife Penelope Cruz was in the last
one did you give you any advice and
working with Johnny well uh the advice
of working with Johnny is very simple
which is have fun and it was like
watching how he became Spyro and it was
a delight I'm so sorry we're still
talking it's license to be a reverend
and to just be stupid what advice would
you give to your younger self 15 years
ago moisturize more does your son know
you're a pirate he asked me like uh do
you really hold your breath that long
data it's very cute and how would these
actors do on the deck of a pirate ship
we take the cast to task testing their
pirate knowledge scallywag openness
cream a rata burnt piece of toast no
poop deck poop deck is the aft of the
ship the back the back it always good
coxswain is one of the crew the captain
of the ship the hounds are yes the
person who steer that don't be brother
of Dumbo is
give you a clue Kim Kardashian oh it's a
pair of high heels buses just brilliant
[Music]
you